now that it has been released on blu-ray
we have access to some bonus content
that can tell us even more about this
world but Andy muschietti has created
and more about the haunting entity that
resides inside of penny wise in this
video I'll break down some of the things
that you may have missed in the blu-ray
bonus content and I'll be discussing
another possible ending to the movie so
be sure to stick around for that this is
things you missed the first bonus video
is all about bringing penny wise to life
and it includes interviews with the kids
about their experiences on set with him
I found myself trying to figure out
Ben's wardrobe choice which was a
t-shirt that features African safari
animals it's something I noticed when I
did my original things you missed videos
when it was in theaters but didn't
include because I hadn't deciphered the
meaning behind it it wasn't until later
in this documentary that I think I
finally figured it out Andy has a thing
with spit and drool I don't know what it
is that appeals him about spit but
there's something about it that he loves
so I got a lot of drool on me she's very
drooly and he brought this to the
character and it's a great thing because
he's like penny wise he gets hungry in
the presence of scared children okay
this makes a lot more sense now I just
went back and looked at the shirt again
and noticed that all of these animals
are the prey just as predators of the
African savannah might salivate over
their meals penny wise salivates over
the fear of children this is also like
two things you missed in one because
everyone has their own individual fears
Beverly has her father Stanley has his
Bar Mitzvah but Eddie is a hypochondriac
he's afraid of germs he's the only one
that penny wise was drilling on thus
making him more afraid and in turn
making penny wise even hungrier so the
cycle repeats itself there's also a
behind-the-scenes shot of that
children's TV show that plays on many of
the TVs and dairy
make it a wonderful guy yeah yeah where
we see essentially the full unobstructed
cast you'll notice that many of the
children sitting there look like zombies
my theory is that these kids are some of
the past and future victims of Pennywise
and once he devours them they may appear
on this show in addition to Ben shirt
another thing I noticed but didn't have
an answer for the first time I saw the
movie was this old-timey tricycle in the
29 niebolt house I assumed it was just
there because it looks circusy and maybe
even as a loose reference to the shining
however in the other character video in
the bonus content we get a better look
at Ritchie shirt from the end of the
movie as I mentioned in a previous video
it reads a dairy bike in cycle shop
which plays into the pattern of its
reemerging on a cycle every 27 years the
graphic on the shirt looks to be the
same tricycle from the house we also see
a doll version of Ritchie in that house
and missing posters with Ritchie's face
on them these are all clues that Ritchie
was supposed to die in this house but he
ends up surviving anyway making the
other piece of text on that shirt life
enjoy the ride all the more appropriate
the nice video features Stephen King
talking about his inspirations for the
book and in it we get a better look at
the drain pipe in most of the scenes
it's very dark but here you can actually
make out an etching of a stick figure
holding balloons if only Patrick
hochstätter had seen that before
venturing into the sewer
onto the deleted scenes one of the
scenes takes place in Henry Bowers room
which is a canvas to his violent
tendencies it's filled with weapons a
road sign covered in bullet holes and
even has a framed picture of a gun which
I find really funny the next one is in
Beverly's room in my previous hit video
I talked about the significance of Bev's
Siouxsie and the Banshees poster and in
this deleted scene we get to see a
little bit more of her punk rock
collection
which includes a Psychedelic Furs poster
this is a pretty beep reference so stick
with me here the Psychedelic Furs really
got off the ground when their song
pretty-in-pink was featured in John
Hughes movie with the same title and if
you've seen that 80s classic you know
that it stars Molly Ringwald which ties
back into its and with this line because
I want to run toward something not away
I'm sorry Molly Ringwald onto the group
Ritchie I'm just saying shortly after
this there's an extended scene where the
Keene girl from the pharmacy
signs Eddie's cast there are two things
to take note of here we get a clear shot
of her necklace showing her name Greta
that makes me think this character could
be a combination of mr. Keens daughter
and Greta Bowie from the book who is a
character who bullies Beverly as seen in
the first school scene in this movie the
other detail was Greta sticking her gum
on the cast at the end which again plays
into the idea that this will really
bother Eddie because he's a
hypochondriac now let's talk about the
last of the deleted scenes which was
originally supposed to be the ending in
the movie in several of the deleted
scenes there's a subplot where Bill's
family plans a vacation to Acadia but
the parents don't want to go anymore
after Georgie's death because Georgie
was really looking forward to going
there so in this final deluded scene
they set off on a new family vacation to
a new destination as a symbolic moving
on from the Georgie cloud that hangs
over this family's head then this
happens
[Music]
I personally really like this ending as
opposed to it ending on Bill and
Beverly's kiss if I were to do it I
would take away the growling sounds to
preserve the mystery of if it was really
defeated I mean even though we know
there's another movie coming but let me
know which ending you liked better in
the comments I actually have one more
thing you missed but it does contain
spoilers so if you haven't read the book
you're gonna want to head over to
another video but please remember to
subscribe and ring that death Bell for
notifications on your way out but for
those of you who have read the novel it
looks like we might be getting that epic
ending in the upcoming hits chapter 2
Ben's room is filled with these daring
newspaper clippings but in the bonus
features we get a closer look at this
one in particular this is a page out of
the 1937
Jerry Courier newspaper this smaller
article is titled special session set
stage for flood control just dropping a
small hint that dairies strange sewer
system may be prone to flooding
of course the it miniseries did drop a
similar hint but then no flood scene was
included but I have a feeling we'll be
seeing at this time around if that's
something you'd like to see go ahead and
give this video a like my name is Susie
and I also write horror here on YouTube
of course I'll be talking about the next
hit movie as soon as that trailer comes
out as well as many of the other big
horror movies before then don't miss out
on it you already know what to do I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive